proposers the midterms are coming and we
need to keep our eyes open for the next
crop of trumps you're not gonna find
them in the middle where the mainstream
lives you're gonna find them on the
outside like the tastiest part of the
pineapple this is fringe watch 2018
tonight today we're looking at West
Virginia Republicans see it as a prime
target for picking up a Senate seat from
the Democratic incumbent joe Manchin a
man so elitist his last name is mansion
who's his chief of staff
Doug infinity pool give me a break this
race is so important Fox News hosted
their Republican primary debate last
night in primetime six months before the
general election and that's a big deal
because Fox had to bump its normal 630
show there's an immigrant in your house
right now so let's see which one of
these three Republican candidates is
going to get into Washington to blow
things up first this is representative
Evan Jenkins former Democrat wolf can't
hear that pass next here we have State
Attorney General Patrick Morrissey
attorney general of what the deep state
drain the swamp next
okay here's John Blankenship CEO okay
explosion in a mine violated safety
standards a year in federal prison whoa
swipe in whatever direction is the sex
one
this is that sweet fridge I've been
craving now I like him on paper he's got
a perfect resume but does he have that
electric showmanship that'll rock an
arena roll this campaign ad politicians
have run a lot of crazy ads they blew up
the coal mine and then put me in prison
now they're running ads that say the
coal mine blew up and I went to prison
there's no surprise there but if you
want jobs if you want to end the drug
epidemic and you want to protect you and
born you need to vote for me one of my
goals as US senator will be to ditch
cocaine Mitch when you vote for me
you're voting for the sake of the kids
how to be clear he didn't mention kids
in that ad until the very end but he did
mention going to jail for a coal mine
explosion twice in the first ten seconds
that's a hell of a campaign ad
blakenship is such an outsider that he
spent twelve months inside a prison
because maybe he conspired to willfully
violate safety standards and a mind he
owned that maybe led to an explosion
that definitely killed 29 people but it
wasn't his fault unless you believe that
several investigations that took place
but who does I trusted investigation as
far as I could obstruct it yeah and you
know we haven't even gotten to this part
ditch cocaine Mitch yes
cocaine Mitch one word nickname it's
very presidential now I'll let Fox his
own Bret Baier explain you have called
the Senate Majority Leader cocaine Mitch
a reference to an allegation that drugs
were found on a ship in 2014
owned by his father-in-law yes that
everyone deserves to be named after
something found on their father-in-law's
ship it's why my nickname is hostage
situation cocaine Mitch just makes sense
that guy is bouncing off the goddamn
walls I wanted to give you the
highlights your hearts gonna explode
but dad's also been catching heat from
liberals for Kali and McConnell's
cocaine boat owning father-in-law a
potentially racist slur but he put that
issue to bed last night
I don't see this the sinew a ssin by the
press that there's something racist
about Sanatana person some people for
Korean persons and some of them are
African persons it's not any slander
there's yeah no big deal I agree it's
just a descriptor plus person is
inclusive like mine explosion person or
employee murderer person and a
blakenship wasn't Trumpy enough for you
don't worry
he brought swag you were going to bring
props and we had to kind of take him
away from these haves that said ditch
Mitch we
we said no to that yes they said no to
that and it's a shame we'll never get to
see those hats due to thee those
airtight policies of Fox News Dam Brett
Bears journalistic integrity
yes Blankenship is clearly the senator
we need in West Virginia a mine
exploding insults Lincoln outsider with
a moustache that says well yes I do
enjoy 1960's pornography and even some
stupid Democrats are getting in on the
Don train with a Democratic super PAC
putting 1.2 million dollars against
Jenkins to try to boost Blankenship
because they think this fringe outsider
could never win a general election
against their candidate a strategy that
has absolutely never backfired so good
luck John you're beautiful outsider I'm
counting on you to keep your campaign
together no matter how good you are at
blowing things up